i call this the rocking chair closed and  i use this when people say i need to  think about it i don't make snap  decisions and this is how i overcome  that let's be real you're not going to  go back to your home sit in your rocking  chair on your deck and be like hmm what  am i going to do am i going to choose to  purchase the thing no of course not  you're going to go home you're going to  realize you have to buy groceries you  have to cook you have to pick up the  kids you got all these other things that  are going on and then three or four days  from hour two or three weeks from now  when we're already full we're gonna be  like oh shoot i guess i should have done  that thing up it's too late now and in  that second you have made the decision  so we might as well confront it now with  me right here and all the information at  your fingertips